Now that we have all of our content set up,
we've tested things and everything seems to be working
the way that we want,
we're now gonna take a look at how we set up our level
from absolutely nothing.
And what I mean by that is what we need to do
in order to basically create a brand new empty open world
and then we're gonna set this up
with everything that is required.
So we're gonna import a height map
and then add our lights and our atmospheric actors
and things like that.
So to get started, what we're gonna do
is we're gonna come over here to the editor,
we're gonna do a file new level
and we're gonna select empty open world.
Now before we jump a little bit further,
there are a few things that I want to explain
about the empty open world map and why it's so important
and the first thing is the grid.
So the grid is the term that we use
to describe our streaming grid
and this grid controls where assets are seen
and more importantly, where they're not seen.
So when we create our world using the open world template
we're already gonna have our world set up
to make use of this grid
and the grid works by loading in the different cells
and you can see the cells marked here
when this loading range approaches them
or gets further away from them
and this loading range is actually connected
to our character.
So we have a streaming source
and in many instances it is going to be the character
and the streaming source defines
the more or less the center of your world
and then as your player progresses throughout the world,
the streaming source is going to allow things
to be streamed in and streamed out.
So that's one of the reasons why we wanna come up here
and make sure that we've gone up to file new level
and created this empty open world map
because then we'll have our world partition enabled
and ready to go.
Now the next thing that we need to do here
is we need to add some actors.
So what we're gonna do is we're gonna add
a directional light, a skylight, sky atmosphere,
volumetric cloud and an exponential height fox.
So let's go ahead and add all of these now.
So we're gonna come up here, we're gonna go quickly add,
we're gonna look for DIR,
we're gonna grab this directional light
and one thing we wanna do with the directional light too
is we wanna come here and just set this to movable
and let's do this now for our sky.
We're gonna grab our skylight and the same thing,
we're gonna take our skylight
and we're gonna set it to movable
and then we're gonna come here
and we're gonna add a sky atmosphere
and then we're gonna add a volumetric cloud
and last but not least,
we're gonna add an exponential height fog.
So I'm gonna leave this menu up here
for just a few moments to let you go ahead
and add all of these actors
and once we come back, what we're gonna do
is we're gonna work on importing our height map.
All right, now that we have all of those actors
placed inside of our level,
we're now going to look at importing a height map.
Now, when you're working with height maps,
there are a few different file formats
that you can work with.
There's gonna be the raw 16, raw eight and PNG.
Now, our 16 is gonna be the best format.
It works with height map data.
The R8 is for weight map data and PNG will work
but it is going to introduce some stair stepping artifacts.
Now, for our purposes, what we're gonna do
is we're gonna come up here and go to landscape
and we're gonna, instead of create a new,
we're gonna go import from file
and what we're gonna do here is the height map file.
I'm gonna press this button right here
and this is going to ask us where we wanna go
and we're gonna come up in here to our files
and to our height maps and we're gonna select this,
I'm not impact, I'm sorry,
the grassy hills base and hit open.
Now, once we do that, we are gonna get a preview
of this landscape and you're gonna notice
that there are these yellow and green areas.
So the yellow is actually the world partition grid side.
So here we can set this so that we are streaming
and basically every landscape component will be in,
I shouldn't say every landscape component
but we will be streaming in four landscape components
per grid so we can set this up here.
Other things that we can do here
is we can adjust our resolution
if we have a varying resolution,
we can set our material here
and then we have the ability to change things
like our location and our scale.
So for us though, the only thing I'm gonna change here
is I'm gonna set this to zero
and then I'm gonna click the import
and this is gonna take a moment to import, there we go
and while that finishes up,
let's just pop back over here to our presentation
because the next thing that we're gonna do
on our landscape and then we're gonna save this
is enable Nanite.
So again, the reason we wanna enable Nanite
on our landscape at this point
is so that when we put the displacement on there,
we are gonna get that displacement
and it's gonna look really cool.
So let's pop back over here to our editor.
So this is our landscape right here
and I'm just gonna disable my fog for right now
so we kinda see what's going on.
So this is what everything is gonna look like
and then what I'm gonna do now
is I'm gonna pop out of our selection mode here
and I'm gonna come to my landscape itself
and go ahead, enable Nanite
and then I'm gonna build my Nanite data.
And once this builds, let's go ahead
and save this as my level or give it a name
and then once that is done,
we're gonna go ahead and move on to editing our level.
All right, now that our Nanite has finished saving
or I should say finished generating,
let's go ahead and just save this
and we're gonna save this as my level.
And once that saves, we will be ready
to start editing our level
and working with various features
and tools inside of the editor.